the five pillars of every longevity died  in the world are whole grains greens  tubers like sweet potatoes nuts and  beans and in fact if you're eating about  a cup of beans a day it's probably  adding about four years to your life  expectancy they are eating some meat but  on average only about five times per  month way less fish and fewer eggs than  you would think no cow's dairy in blue  zones by the way and when they're  drinking it's mostly water about six  glasses a day teasing coffee because if  you want to know what a centenarian  eight to live to be a hundred you have  to know what they were eating when they  were 10 and when they were young adults  in middle age and retired you can't just  ask a centenarian what they've been  eating lately and what emerges is a very  clear pattern whether you're in Asia  Europe Latin America United States  they're eating 90 to 100 Whole Food  plant-based